Speaker 1: All right, listen to this.
Remember Milo Yiannopoulos? Milo Yiannopoulos
was a he's still British. Milo
Yiannopoulos was a guy gay British man,
former guest on this program. He won't come out
anymore. I've invited him to figure out what's
going on with them. Won't come out anymore. Milo
Yiannopoulos. He became a right wing darling.
His framing was, Listen, I am a I think he. He
was gay, Catholic and Jewish. I don't know if who
knows what of this stuff is even true. And his
whole position was the left can't go after me.
As one of these homophobic whatever right wingers,
because I'm gay and Catholic and Jewish or,
you know, all the all the different things. He
then was, I want to be careful with the language.
He then was on video. Sort of defending,
I'm not going to use some of the words that
were used to describe it because I don't
think it was accurate. He was on video
defending. Sexual contact between adults
and what are legally children. And that
kind of torpedoed his career and he disappeared
for a while and then more recently, he has kind
of attempted to rehabilitate himself by saying
I am now heterosexual. He says he's no longer
gay and. Yeah. Make of that what you will.
And he's also now, I guess, a much more devout
Catholic. That's another part of it. So he's been
appearing on like Real America's Voice, I think,
and all these different right wing places. And
it just he's like, not really getting traction.
So a viewer says David Milo is now
selling statuettes of the Virgin Mary.
On unlike a Christian version of the
home shopping network, and I said,
guys, this can't possibly be true, it's going to
be some kind of satire. It's not. It's not. Milo
Yiannopoulos is now selling Virgin Mary statues
and other religious paraphernalia on something
called church militant store. Just look at this.
Speaker 5: Hello, and welcome to the church,
Martin Shop. My name is Milo Yiannopoulos, and
I'm here with my co-host Deborah Vaughn opening
statement. I'm doing OK. How are you? I'm well,
I'm happy because this is the first of our shows
and we're beginning today with, well, probably
the most important woman in history when you say,
I think so. She's certainly the most beloved, and
we've got today three items all in celebration.
Reverence, of course, of the blessed mother.
Speaker 1: Extremely powerful religious items
Speaker 5: here, the Virgin Mary. We're
going to start with this wonderful statue,
which we both own. We do, but in different media
up different colors. That's right. You've got the
silver finish. And I've got this bronze finish.
Speaker 1: So for the low, low price of 87 50,
you can get the adoring Virgin statue with made
from cold cast poly resin and either bronze or
silver. Perfect for some kind
of strange basement altar
or just keeping on your bedside table. If you're
ever having trouble sleeping and need to look at
something that will calm you down. Order now.
Speaker 5: Tell us a little bit about the
material this is made from. Because it's not a
specialist, it looks like it's going to weigh
a ton and cost $100 to ship, and I want to
make sure I have it right. So it's it's a
cold cast and it's hand-painted bronze
color, or you can get it in the pewter.
Sometimes it's one or the other might be
on backorder, but they come in. It's very
popular, right? It. I have a shrine at home.
Speaker 1: Is this funny or is it depressing,
guys? Is it? Is it just depressing
that this is what Milo is now doing?
Speaker 5: Now I have mine in in my
shrine and it looks very, very nice.
Speaker 1: Well, I was joking about
putting it in an altar, but the
woman's literally saying, I have a shrine at
Speaker 5: home and you know it. It's called the
adoring Virgin, and I adore her. I actually have
a rosary hanging from her. I do the same thing.
Do you do the same thing? One of the nice things
about this particular statue, yes, is the shroud.
And on your silver version, something shows up on
the back a little bit more than on this one. This
is more of a sort of like an age metal finish
on the silver one. You get a little bit more of
the detail popping out, I think, but I'm just
to that's a contrast to color, right? I mean,
turning this around, and maybe you could explain
to us a little bit about shroud. So the shroud?
Speaker 1: Oh my god. So then they get into
a different I want to find this other moment
they start talking about, I guess now they move
into selling a Bible. This is a year with Mary
Daly meditations on the mother of God. This is a
very special Bible. Milo has now put his glasses
on for this because it's very, very serious
Speaker 5: or blind, because I think, you know,
just I'm just not sure what I'm going
to get out of it because some of it's,
you know, it's just a lot of historical
names listed. This is selected to be
endlessly fascinating, you know, every
day it's a completely different tone
and style. And also there's lots of St
Alphonsus Liguori, but there's also,
you know, Ludi mournful Pope Benedict, the 16th,
all kinds of different meditations and thoughts
on Mary. So I thought I'd read one from a
fellow Brit, the blessed John Henry Newman.
Speaker 1: So Milo will now read
a meditation on the Virgin Mary
from a Bible you can buy for 45 bucks.
Speaker 5: So this British writing always
sounds better. Always love to hear you read.
Well, thanks, so I'll just read you. This is
day one hundred and fifty five. So there because
it is the numbers so you can start it at any time,
but you don't have to wait until January
to start your year with her. You can just
you can keep track yourself, thank
Speaker 1: God, right? I mean, imagine
having to wait until January to start the readings
Speaker 5: if we just use a pencil to check them
off or something. So it's called Mary Vessel
of devotion. And in this, the blessed John
Henry Newman illustrates the meaning of
devotion and shows how our lady overflowed
with devotion to her son. Hmm. To be devout.
Speaker 1: OK, and I'm going to stop it there
because I know I'm trying to. I'm trying to
prevent a cringe stream today. This is surreal,
guys. This is completely and totally surreal. And
if you go to the church militant shop, you can get
everything from Catholic mugs to package deals,
including prayer books and various different
elements. You can get a Catholic Mehta T-shirt.
You can also buy metals even in art deco style,
guys. What the hell is going on in this country
or any country for that matter, Milos? You know,
he's British. Let me know whether this
is sad, funny or something in between.